okay let's go to our other top story
this summer the uk health
regulator has approved the oxford
astrazeneca coronavirus vaccine for
emergency use the government's already
pre-ordered a hundred
million doses that paves the way for a
huge expansion of the government's
inoculation program it's got
implications around the world
because it's by far the cheapest vaccine
to buy
of those approved so far and it's easier
to distribute than the pfizer biontech
shop
uk prime minister boris johnson's
welcomed the announcement calling it a
triumph for british science he's added
that the uk is now going to move to
vaccinate as many people
as quickly as possible let's speak to
rory challens in
london rory this has obviously been a
significant step ahead but
the question is of course is it going to
be enough to be able to deal with the
numbers
of people who are infected in the uk
yeah well 100 million doses assuming
that that is actually what is
delivered uh is enough to cover 50
million people it's a two dose medicine
so you need a one shot in the arm and
then you wait 12 weeks and then you get
a
another injection with your second dose
so 50 million people that's a big chunk
of the uk
population which i think is about 60
million something like that
so it's a huge step forward and it
couldn't have come
at a better time really because the
situation
in the uk has been worsening
significantly over the last few days
for two days running we've had uh record
numbers of new infections we had 53
000 new injection new infections
yesterday but we had
in excess of 40 000 new infections the
day before
we have more people in hospital at the
moment some
in excess of 20 000 with covet than
there were at the peak of the first wave
so things are getting significantly
worse here
the government we understand is today
going to
extend the the tiered system of
restrictions on
on lockdown essentially regional
lockdowns around the country
so good news is needed and this is very
good news
and it's good news because this
injection is much
more easy to use much more easy to
transport
and administer than the vaccine that's
being used at the moment which is the
pfizer biontech one
they're both they both work and they're
both safe
they wouldn't have been authorized
otherwise but this one is cheaper
it's more easy to use and therefore it's
it can vaccinate more people
more quickly and obviously a lot of
people in the uk are going to be pinning
their hopes on this because the uk
you and i were talking about this just a
couple of days ago is facing the
prospect of
possibly yet another lockdown into the
new year as well
yeah so the the the the concerning
information that's
coming out at the moment is that this
new
uh variant of the virus has
spread so widely and so fast
that medical experts or some medical
experts are warning that
2000 sorry 2021 could be worse
uh than 2020 in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths
and the level of vaccination that's
going on at the moment which is about
200
000 people a week is just not fast
enough to be able to combat that
and also that the the restrictions that
the country is under
are just not tough enough so there is
still
a likelihood a high likelihood that even
with this vaccine
uh being authorized for for immediate
rollout
the uh there will need to be uh
tougher measures taken when it comes to
restrictions on people's lives and i
think what people are most worried about
particularly
is that schools are going to be closed
again we don't know that for sure but
that is the way the wind is blowing that
as this new variance of the of the virus
affects
younger people more than the older
version did
it seems prudent to at least put stone
restrictions
on pupils mingling in schools move
pupils out of classrooms back into their
homes and do online or homeschooling
again
parents will groan that but that's the
way it's likely to go
rory thank you very much indeed rory
charles bringing us up to date from
london